eeuu ha batido otro récord mundial de
kobe 19 esta vez con más de un millón de
contagios en un día un repunte causado
por la variante omicron y que los
expertos opinan afectará sobre todo a
los no vacunados
tenemos estas dos vías las de los no
vacunados y las de los vacunados y los
no vacunados son los que nos frenan en
términos de seguir preocupándonos por la
capacidad hospitalario así con casi el
doble de casos que hace tan solo cuatro
días este aumento podría explicarse con
las largas colas de estadounidenses para
hacerse pruebas de detección con motivo
de las festividades navideñas y a pesar
de que el ejecutivo estadounidense ha
descartado otro confinamiento si se
están planteando otras medidas como la
vacunación de refuerzo para adolescentes
de 12 a 15 años aprobada recientemente
por la edad debido a la alta incidencia
del virus entre menores
estamos viendo niños que llegan con los
síntomas clásicos de insuficiencia
respiratoria que necesitan oxígeno o
máquinas para respirar como ventiladores
muchos requieren atención en la uci algo
muy parecido a lo que hemos visto
durante toda la pandemia solo que ahora
estamos viendo mucho más
con un alto índice de casos en
diferentes países de la región el
continente americano ha entrado en 2022
con 102 millones de contagios un número
que todavía podría ir al alza